(metal clanging)
- I'm a fighter, because that's
all I've known how to be.
My name is Tanya Smith
and I'm a competitive historical fencer.
We train in a system developed
by a 14th century master
and practiced until the 16th century.
We've built a really
awesome community of women
and we're all doing it together.
(hard rock music)
I train and teach in long
sword, it's my primary weapon.
I'm 5'2" and my long sword
comes up to shoulder level.
It's empowering and fun.
You can use it to cut,
you can use it to thrust,
you can get close in range and grapple
and really just kick ass with.
Classes were very, very
small in the beginning.
It felt like I was the only woman.
And being the token girl
it was something I was
comfortable with at first,
but as I got better
and as I started developing
my goals as a fighter,
I realized I wanted to have a community
of other women with shared philosophies.
An event I planned was
a women's tournament,
one of the first of its kind in the U.S.
People will view a women's event as lesser
but I shouldn't have to beat someone
who's double my height or double my weight
to prove that I'm a good fencer.
The standard should be
beating the best fighters.
Women make good fighters
because they want to be there.
They put their heart and souls into it.
You don't do this because
you're forced to be there.
You don't do this
because there's an
expectation to be there.
They do it because they're
passionate about it.